ever takes on this mantle sure so the
new first Minister will have a full
entry the normal problems the the
problems that every leader is facing
right now cost of living Energy prices
economics but also education and NHS
wait times at the same time they'll be
faced with reunifying their party after
this bitter contest and figuring out and
after the UK government has said no to
another referendum and the Supreme Court
has backed them up on that how to pursue
the S and peace raise and better thought
of Independence
and that battle for Independence which
is at the heart of the SNP it wasn't
something that enormously featured in in
the in the campaign and perhaps
unusually you know that all all sides
all of the candidates of course would be
in favor of it
but but big questions for the s p about
whether it is the right time to put it
again to the pub the public of course
then we see from the polling that the
population is roughly evenly divided
between those in favor of Independence
and those against Independence so in
order to move the dial on that something
will have to happen but is that possible
at a time of a pretty significant
political and economic uncertainty
how damaged do you think the party has
been and indeed has it been damaged At
All by this campaign because it is as
you said in your first answer it has
always been a party that's been
um very tightly controlled very very
um strategic and how they operate a very
very close ship but we've seen a lot of
differences within the party over the
last few weeks I absolutely and there's
a few main divides over over the pursuit
of Independence over gender records the
gender recognition Reform Act and it'll
be difficult to put that Coalition back
together historically the party has been
focused on pursuing its independence
subjective it's a broad Church of a
party which incorporates lots of
different ideologies and opinions on
things Beyond Independence but how do
you get everyone moving in the same
direction again
and in terms of the membership of the s
p of course it was only just revealed in
the last few weeks that its membership
wasn't a hundred thousand it was around
the 70 000 mark
why do you think they've lost so so much
Support over the last year so we don't
have a great member service of the SMP
in recent years that we can speculate
though we can speculate that people left
because they were impatient about
independence or perhaps they were
disillusioned with the party support or
pursuit of gender recognition reform
um but we don't really know why we saw
that quite dramatic jump it's still a
huge party in terms of its membership
but is that membership more or less
cohesive after those 30 000 have
departed and and we don't know why
they've left but do we know where
they've gone to do we know whether these
are people who are now politically
disenfranchised or have they gone to
labor have gone to conservative have
they gone to the greens we don't know
because we haven't seen the membership
numbers from the other parties
um so they may have just opted out of
Party politics for the time being they
may have just let their memberships
laughed but they might have also gone to
other parties or they might be
I have an opportunity for other parties
to pursue
and and of the campaign itself I mean
yes it is it has been a little bit bad
tempered some would say but but what
have you made of it it's an interesting
Campaign which is focused more on
Devolution and the quality of governance
and the the policies of the party of
government rather than the pursuit of
Independence so we have seen these kind
of bad tempered exchanges whether
whether the last 13 years of government
is one of mediocrity or is it a high
quality government
um people defending their records and
attacking the records of their opponents
so it has been focused on the policy
issues that are facing people things
around the performance of the Scottish
economy around the bringing end of the
bottle deposit scheme gender recognition
Etc
okay and Corey we'll be coming back to
you in a minute but we can cross now to
Conor Gillis who is at Murray Field
where that announcement is going to be
made in less than 10 minutes time
excitement presumably building there
Connor are there any rumors are you able
to see any huddles of any of the
particular teams to give us any clues
yeah excitement uh building from each of
the three camps here at Murray Field in
the last few minutes just uh here is the
Hamza Yusuf Camp his supporters over on
the other side of the room just beyond
the podium there is the supporters for
Cape Forbes and then a much smaller
audience supporting Ash Regan in this
contest as well some well-known faces
here in Scotland in terms of members of
the Scottish Parliament uh backing Hamza
Yusuf he has the clear support the clear
majority support from the elected
officials here in Scotland when it comes
to this contest Kate Forbes well she
lost quite uh sizable amount of support
early on in this contest many
politicians pooling out of her campaign
because of those comments that she made
around her faith saying that she would
have voted against equal marriage had
she been an MSP here in Scotland at the
time she then went on to tell Sky News
that she thought because of her faith
the that it would be wrong to have
children outside of marriage at that
point many of these politicians said
we're cutting our losses we're not
supporting Cape Forbes in a way that we
maybe thought we would do initially let
me just talk you through the
choreography of exactly what will happen
so we've got the Huddle of the press
photographers just up there we can see
uh beside the podium and the stage
itself the live television camera is
about to bring you that uh moment in
just a few minutes we'll bring it to you
here on Sky News as well we are
expecting the business convener from the
SMP uh an MP called Kirsten Oswald to
take to the stage and to make some
opening remarks and at that point then
the national secretary Lorna Flynn
will deliver the result that everyone is
waiting for here in Edinburgh today it
has been a long contest uh and but many
people have suggested others have said
it wasn't long enough this has thrown
the SMP into arguably its most difficult
position in quite a number of years here
in Scotland the candidates the three
candidates two of whom are serving
cabinet ministers in Nicholas sturgeon's
now former government I suppose live on
television it was a slagging match at
times around each of their track records
and whether they have done a good enough
job and whether that will steer them
into this highest office in the land the
position of first minister of Scotland
and the SNP has been through a pretty
bruising encounter as well it revealed
during this contest after pretty
sustained pressure I think it's fair to
say
membership numbers dwindling membership
numbers initially said it was not going
to reveal those numbers it had been
thought around 100 000 members were
taking part in this shock contest
following Nicola sturgeon's resignation
uh the party refused on a number of
occasions to reveal its figures and then
it came that pressure and suddenly it
revealed a drop of around 30 000 members
of the Scottish national party in the
last 18 months and an even bigger steep
decline in the last few months following
that row over gender reforms it has led
not only to the resignation as we know
that's why we're here first Minister
Nicholas sturgeon is going the deputy
first Minister John Swinney a
long-standing Ally of Nicholas sturgeon
he's been in government for very many
years he's been at the top of the SMP
hierarchy for decades he's going uh the
head of communications for the SMP quit
as well over that membership row that we
have just been discussing and then
laterally came that pressure from the
chief executive Peter who quit as well
now it's just got very quiet here in the
room we are just a few minutes away five
minutes or so from the moment itself
more people are filing in including the
campaign manager so let's just go over
here and see uh what's going on here and
we'll just bring you along the back the
row of cameras
um
ready to take in this moment
and uh
that is
a Yusuf campaign manager just taking his
at the front uh just in front of us here
are all the journalists who have been uh
Conrad I don't know if you can hear me I
think you may have strayed a little bit
too far we're just now have lost your
microphone so maybe if you could move
back a little bit closer but this kind
of moves back a little closer towards us
to
Brown swan
um who's here with me and Corey we were
talking to John Curtis the polling
expert a little earlier and he was
pointing out one key thing that's going
to happen as a result of this is that
whoever wins be it home to yourself or
Kate Forbes it does seem very likely
it'll be ashrigan that they've but
they've got really different challenges
haven't they that the homes of Yousef
has to
has to look outwards has to get more
people involved in the SNP has to to
bring in more people to it whereas it
seems that Kate Forbes is going to have
to do a lot of work to to bring people
on side inside the party of course so I
think comes to yourself has the
challenge of building a case for
Independence reaching out beyond the SMP
while Kate forbes's attentions in the
first first months and weeks and months
of her term will have to be restoring
that trust within the s p building that
Coalition the Coalition within the SNP
and then perhaps some sort of continued
relationship with the greens who've been
quite critical of Cape Forbes in recent
weeks
that the campaign itself has also
brought a lot of people to question the
links between faith and politics and
whether or not you can have a very
strong faith and whether or not that
that conflicts with with politics and
whether it's possible to have hold the
two separately and together yes
definitely so it's been something that
we perhaps didn't expect to be
discussing at the very beginning of this
campaign but we have seen these
discussions both of Kate forbes's faith
and how that might impact her policy
making where to where she to become
first Minister she is sad because of a
person have strong religious Faith
should be able to to be to govern and
would govern in a way that was
acceptable to people it's really up to
the s p membership whether that that is
the case in the end and but but Hamza
Yusuf also of course a a religious man
do you think that she's perhaps been
unfairly focused on throughout this I
think I'm so Yusuf was so it was perhaps
um a bit more Polished in his delivery
of answers or his delivery and and his
argument that his faith wouldn't
necessarily impact his governing Kate
Forbes obviously has had that challenge
of being questioned on matters of of
religion and how that would impact her
her perspective on things and whether
Scotland would truly be Progressive
under her leadership but I do think
there's perhaps a double standard
perhaps people feel less comfortable
speaking about different religions
religions that are not the majority of
religion
um when questioning political candidates
I think we can go back to Connor Connor
Gillis who is there in the room can you
hear us now Connor what's going on there
yeah here we go uh this moment is coming
in the next few seconds in at the last
moment or so
uh Kate Forbes her husband has taken her
seat along with their newborn baby of
course Kate Forbes has been on maternity
leave from her role as the head of the
country's economy and they have taken
their position here
um just in the far distance you can see
a row of empty chairs that is where some
people from Ash Regan's Camp still have
to take at their place here coming in to
sit down now and quite a sizable number
just beside us here where we are
standing at the edge of this room at
four Hamza Yusuf so we are expecting
this to uh happen in the next 30 seconds
or so we the candidates will emerge
through a door in the other corner of
this room and we will have the business
convener from the SNP welcoming the
guests welcoming the journalists and of
course welcoming everyone watching at
home because this is not just a contest
to elect the leader of the Scottish
national party this is of course
ultimately who is likely to become the
next first minister in a formal ceremony
at Hollywood tomorrow a formal vote that
will take place and so there's a lot at
stake here
and this is what will be uh being
revealed in the next couple of seconds
or so we're expecting to find out the
total number of votes cast and then
crucially how those votes were split now
this voting system
uh will be we're all ears are out for of
any of the three candidates get 50 of
the vote plus one at that point we will
know uh the way that this is going I'm
just looking in the far distance as we
await for this moment
for those candidates the room is packed
to the rafters with cameras with
journalists
um ready to catch this moment because of
course let's remember the SMP has not
been in this position
for almost 20 years no leadership
contest similar to this
um since
Alex salmond was
elected to the leader of the party so
this is unfamiliar territory for the SMP
who of course are Scotland's largest
party who are I think it's fair to say
an election winning operation under
Nicholas sturgeon's watch won each of
the elections that they fought and that
will be the task for whoever takes over
here in Edinburgh in the next few
minutes how will they
pick up the mantle from what Nicholas
sturgeon and her predecessor Alex
salmond have built over the course of
the last 15 20 years here in Scotland
will that electoral success continue uh
will opposition politicians take
advantage of uh this change in
leadership
um and try and capitalize
in a in a way that they have failed to
do
over the course of the last decade
certainly labor hoping for that's hoping
to take advantage here in Scotland now
I'm just telling you that we're two
minutes past two as it stands and all
eyes are still firmly fixed on the
corner of this room for the candidates
to come through and to
reveal this moment
as you were saying obviously this
audience is going to be the next leader
of the SNP but it isn't a given that
that they will become first Minister I
mean it would be extraordinary if they
didn't but just talk us through what
happens after they've become the leader
of the SNP and the mechanisms for them
then becoming first minister
yes so that is true this afternoon we
will of course in the next few minutes
get the result of who will become the
SNP leader but there is a process unlike
at Westminster where
tomorrow uh msps will gather at
Hollywood and there will be a moment
for a vote
and at that point it is highly likely
given the numbers we're talking about
here in terms of the smps numbers within
Hollywood uh that whoever is standing on
the podium within the next few minutes
will be that next first Minister let's
not rule anything out you can't rule
anything out in politics at the moment
but I think it's a fairly uh
uh yeah we can conclude that
um without doubt
um but let's just also think as well
around the entry of issues that await
this new SMP leader
uh first of all the issue of
Independence that mission that Nicholas
sturgeon and Alex salmon failed to
deliver of course Mr salmon brought
Scotland to the brink of Independence
back in 2014
but many I think within the party have
been unhappy at how the dial has not
shifted further given the issues that
the party sees around brexit over the
course of the last few years the dial
hasn't shifted as much as many of the
itching members of the Scottish national
party would like how will this new
leader shift the dial on that and then
of course we've got other issues like
the Health Service which opponents would
suggest is in crisis at the moment one
of the candidates standing here due to
walk through this door any second now
Hamza Yusuf has been in charge of
Scotland's Health Service for a number
of years and critics have been damning
of his record record waiting times for
patients how will he or Cape Forbes or
actually can turn the fortunes of the
Health Service around and then of course
there's the um other big issue that the
SMP has been grappling with over the
course of the last few months and
has led to infighting in a way that has
not been the case over the course of the
last few years within the SMP the issue
around gender reforms now
Hamza Yusuf has said he fully supports
that legislation that was passed just
before Christmas
but it's a very different story
altogether from Kate Forbes and Ash
Regan Forbes his position she told Sky
News just a few weeks ago in the early
days of this contest uh that she would
not be in favor of 16 and 17 year olds
being able to legally change their
gender Ash Regan in a similar boat and
they would not entertain this and the
moment is now happening let's listen
speaker
and and Connor while we wait for for
that announcement just remind us about
the voting system here it's a single
transferable vote system isn't it a bit
the same that uh they are walking in
Let's uh let's just listen in let's
listen and try and get some of the
atmosphere
thank you
good afternoon and welcome to
murrayfield my name is Kirsten Oswald
and I am the SNP business convener and
I'm delighted to be here today at the
culmination of this election contest to
choose our new SNP leader
the contest has taken our three
candidates the length and breadth of
Scotland they've beamed into our living
rooms via TV debates and they've worked
tirelessly to engage with members all
over the country
so this is a historic moment for the SNP
and as we look forward to our new leader
I want to thank Nicholas sturgeon for
her exceptional leadership over the past
eight and a half years
I'd also like to convey my thanks to the
candidates to our members and to
everyone at snphq and our national
executive committee who've worked so
hard behind the scenes to deliver this
important exercise in party democracy
and I'm delighted to Welcome to the
stage to announce a review leader Lorna
Finn SNP National secretary
as National Secretary of the SNP I have
been given the results of the party
leader election 2023 from my voice the
ballot Services Company
these are as follows
the final number of eligible members was
72 169.
a total of 50
494 ballot papers containing a valid
vote were received there were three
rejected postal ballot papers the
turnout was therefore 70 percent
645 of the ballots were cast
electronically and
1849 of the ballots were cast by post
the first preference votes are as
follows
Ash Regan
5599 this represents 11.1 percent of
gross preference votes
Kate Forbes twenty thousand five hundred
and fifty nine this represents 48.7
percent of the first preference votes
Hamza Yusuf 24
336 this represents 48.2 percent of the
first preference votes
as no candidate received more than fifty
percent of the votes Ash Reagan as the
candidate who received the least number
of Air Force preferences was eliminated
and the second preference votes in favor
of Cape Forbes or Hamza Yusuf were given
to them
the result after those votes were
redistributed was as follows Kate Forbes
890 this represents 47.9 of the final
vote
Hamza Yusuf 26 000 and 32 this
represents a 52.1 final vote
I therefore declare Hamza Yusuf Julie
elected as the Scottish national party
leader
congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
can I begin by thanking our national
secretary Lorna Finn and also can I
thank our headquarters staff for all the
incredible efforts that they have made
right throughout this process
it is hard for me to find the words to
describe just how honored I am to be
entrusted by our membership of the SNP
to be the parties next leader and to be
on the cusp of being our country's next
first minister
can I begin by paying tribute to my
colleagues both Kate and Ash during
almost 20 hostings it's probably fell
like we've seen each other more than we
have our respective families you both
have put in an incredible shift and I
know that collectively we will continue
to work hard as part of Team SNP
uh I am not just humbled of that I most
certainly am I also feel like the
luckiest man in the world to be standing
here as the leader of the SNP a party I
joined almost 20 years ago and that I
love so dearly
friends it was the late John Smith and
he got it absolutely right when he said
the opportunity to serve our country is
all we ask
to serve my country as first Minister
will be the greatest privilege in honor
of my life should Parliament decide to
elect me as Scotland's next first
Minister tomorrow
and just as I will lead the SNP in the
interests of all party members
not just those who voted for me so I
will aim to lead Scotland in the
interests of all of our citizens
whatever your political allegiance if
elected as your first Minister after
tomorrow's vote in Parliament know that
I will be a first Minister for all of
Scotland the I will work every minute of
every day to earn and to re-air your
respect and your trust
I will do that by treating you the
people of Scotland with respect
there will be no empty promises or easy
sound bites when the issues in front of
us are difficult and complex because
government is not easy and I won't
pretend that it is
my immediate priority will be to
continue to protect every Scott as far
as we possibly can from the harm
inflicted by the cost of living crisis
to recover and reform our NHS and other
vital public services to support our
well-being economy to improve the life
chances of people right across this
country I will move quickly to develop
plans to extend child care to improve
rural housing support small businesses
and boost Innovation I will bring
forward reforms of the Criminal Justice
System I work with local government to
empower our local authorities
and as first Minister I will not shy
away from those exceptionally tough
challenges that require the difficult
decisions
but with this challenge I will use it to
also find opportunity
my government will seize the economic
and social opportunity that the journey
to Net Zero will bring a country is
energy rich as Scotland should not have
people living in fuel poverty the
government I lead will renew and
redouble our efforts to lift people out
of poverty to make work fair to make our
economy work for the people and to
ensure as we become a more prosperous
country we also become a fairer country
too
and while I have had my fair share of
battles with the UK government over the
years and there may well be some to come
I will work with them and other devolved
Nations constructively where I can in
the best interests of our nation
I'm a pro-scott an equally a proud
European too and Scotland is a European
nation we want to return to the European
Union and play our part in building a
continent that's based on human rights
on peace prosperity and social justice
to the people of Scotland the SNP has
earned your trust by governing well
by ensuring that your priorities are our
priorities
as a party and as a government we are at
our best when we are radical and Bold
and the challenges we face today they
require nothing less of us
that is what I promised the people of
Scotland if parliament of course puts
its trust in me tomorrow
joining the SNP for me was an act of
Hope but it was also a statement of
intent I was determined then as I am now
that we will deliver Independence for
Scotland
together
as a team
leadership elections by their very
nature can be bruising however in SNP we
are a family over the last five weeks we
may have been competitors or supporters
of different candidates we are no longer
team Hamza or team Ash or team Kate we
are one team and we will be the team we
will be the generation that delivers
Independence for Scotland
where there are divisions to heal we
must do so quickly because we have a job
to do as a party we are at our strongest
when we are united and what unites us is
our shared goal of delivering
Independence for our nation
to those in Scotland who don't yet quite
share that passion that I do for
Independence I will aim to earn your
trust by continuing to ensure we govern
well and earn your respect as first
Minister by focusing on the priorities
that matter to all of us and in doing so
using our devolved powers to the
absolute maximum effect to tackle the
challenges of the day
and for those of us in this room and
watching who do believe in Independence
we will only win by making that case on
the doorsteps and my solemn promise and
commitment to you is that I will
kick-start our Grassroots our Civic LED
movement and ensure our drive for
Independence is in fifth gear the people
of Scotland need Independence now more
than ever before and we will be the
generation that delivers Independence
for Scotland
before concluding
I want to take the opportunity to thank
some very very special people indeed and
I wouldn't be standing here today if it
wasn't for the support and the
encouragement of a number of
hard-working people
first of all there is my amazing wife
Nadia she is not just my rock she is my
compass who helps to guide me through
the most difficult times in life there
but there is no way not a chance in hell
that I would be standing here if it was
not for your love for your support and
for your advice thank you for believing
me and for always being there for me I
will love you more and I do love you
more than words uh more than the words
that I can find to express to my girls
this job will at times be all-consuming
I suspect but know that there is no more
important job in my life than being your
dad to Maya and Mao you will always
always come first
to my mom to my dad to my sisters
thank you for your unwavering support
throughout my life for picking me up
when I have been down and for telling me
to keep going when at times I had my
doubts I'd also like to thank my
phenomenal campaign team you have worked
day and night over the last few weeks to
support me you've all sacrificed time
with your family and your friends
because like me you believe in our
vision of a progressively Progressive
socially just Scotland and I will not
let you down a special mention to Neil
gray he is quite simply the best corner
man I could have asked for during the
roller coaster of emotion that is any
leadership contest you have been by my
side and there's no way I would have
made it to the Finish Line without your
support and to my good friend and
colleague Shawna Robinson your wise
counsel has been indispensable to me
doing this contest
to our now former leader Nicholas
sergeant and her Deputy in government
John Swinney thank you for your
dedicated service to this party to our
country and to all the people of
Scotland you have left me strong
foundations to build upon
and thank you to my colleagues and both
parliaments across local government and
activists around the country who have
been so supportive and so encouraging I
will share that I have and I will ensure
that I harness all of the talent across
the party and across the country as I
build that team that will take Scotland
forward to deliver our nation's
independence from our brilliant MPS led
abley by Stephen Flynn and by Mary Black
in Westminster to our leaders in local
government as well as our exceptional
group of msps in the Scottish Parliament
our Parliament has an array of talent
right through its ranks our
parliamentarians our councilors our
activists our members all have a vital
part to play on our journey to
Independence as do our friends right
across the independence movement to have
your confidence as I take on the role as
SNP leader means so much to me
my final thanks is to my grandparents
unfortunately they're no longer alive to
see this date but I'm forever forever
thankful
that my grandparents made the trip from
Punjab to Scotland over 60 years ago
as immigrants to this country who knew
barely a word of English they could not
have imagined and their wildest dreams
that their grandson would one day be on
the cusp of being the next first
minister of Scotland
as Muhammad Yusuf worked in the Singer
sewing machine factory in clydebank
as rahmat Ali Buddha stamped tickets on
the Glasgow Corporation buses
they could not have imagined as I say in
the wildest dreams that two generations
later that their grandson would one day
be on the cusp of being Scotland's first
Minister we should all take pride in the
fact that today we have sent a clear
message that your color of skin or
indeed your faith is not a barrier to
Leading the country that we all call
home
from the Punjab to our Parliament this
is a journey over Generations that
reminds us we should be celebrating and
always celebrate the migrants who
contribute so much to our country
this is what drives my commitment to
equality that will underpin my actions
as first minister
thank you for the honor of choosing me
to be your nominee to become to become
Scotland's sixth first minister
I will dedicate every waking moment to
serving you
the people of Scotland thank you very
much
thank you
foreign
we are going to take some questions from
the Press I think there was a list that
was given to me and we'll come to that
sure there we go we want to take some
questions here uh for the pests uh BBC
James Cook
thanks so much indeed congratulations on
the historic nature of your election
Victory you have suggested during this
campaign that it will be difficult to
fill the shoes of Nicholas sturgeon as a
politician of considerable stature and
yet on the central defining mission of
your party Independence ultimately she
failed what makes you think you can
succeed where she couldn't
so first and foremost I want to pitch up
you again to Nicola sturgeon because she
has left us with a really strong
foundation and we will build upon that
Foundation I will build upon that
Foundation but it won't just be me I'm
going to build the team that's going to
deliver Independence I've already spoken
throughout this campaign of how much
admiration I have for both the
colleagues who join me in this
leadership contest but I've also spoken
about the array of talent in the
parliament's Scottish Westminster
Parliament across local government that
will help to build that team that
delivers Independence so it's thanks to
Nicholas dungeon it's thanks to John
Swinney it's thanks to those strong
foundations that they left us that we
will go on to finish the job Thanks
James uh call McKay STV
congratulations this has been a bruising
contest for your party the result shows
just how divided it is how do you start
by uniting your party and then regaining
the trust of the people of Scotland in a
Scottish government
well first and foremost after I've
spoken to the media one of the first
meetings I expect to have and would like
to have it would be with Kate and Ash
because it is important that the party
comes together I try to stress that my
opening and my remarks that we are at
our strongest as a party when we are
united and what unites us is the goal of
the living Independence for Scotland so
of course election contests by their
nature can be challenging they can open
up some divisions but I've got no doubt
not just faith and myself but I have
absolute faith in my colleagues Ash and
and Kate that we will come together and
there will be no team Hamza there will
be no team Kate there will be no team
Ash there will be a team SMP and it will
be team SMP that will deliver
Independence for our country
Channel 4.
congratulations
um does this outcome tell you that
obviously a lot of people wanted your
opponent to and almost 48 of them
offering are quite a different approach
you with the continuity candidate in
this election does this result tell you
that continuity won't cut it
well I'm delighted to be standing here
as the person that the majority of
membership have put their faith in but
what I will do is of course reach across
the device that may well exist I've
always said as much as I admire and
respect Nicola and I really do I will be
my own man I will be I will do
leadership my own way and one of those
ways will be to have as big a tent as
possible and that includes of course the
various different uh the various
different platforms that have been put
forward by my colleagues I want to speak
to them as soon as I'm finished speaking
to you because we have to harness not
just the talent but the idea is that my
colleagues have brought forward so as
I've said the other colleagues who've
already asked questions I don't view
this as there being factions or teams
there's going to be one team that's
going to deliver us independence in
terms of the government we are still of
course the party that is more trusted
than any other political party in
Scotland I'll not take that for granted
I'll not be complacent about that but we
have won the trusted people of Scotland
because we have delivered for them and
that is my aim to continue to deliver
for the people of Scotland
just behind you
uh congratulations uh first of all um
the polls were suggesting throughout the
contest that you of the three candidates
were the most incompetent weak and
untrustworthy how are you going to turn
that around and not fail on the S P's
election winning machine that it has
been over the course of the last few
years well I'm delighted to be part of
that election winning machine and being
part of government for 10 and a half
years but on top of that of course I'm
delighted that when I've stood for
election I've been elected and
re-elected with a big majority from the
people of Glasgow Pollock who I'd like
to thank and putting their trust in me
uh over the years but what I'll make
sure I do is I govern and govern what in
the interest of the people of Scotland
but also we win the trust of the people
of Scotland when we govern uh and be
align with their priorities their
priorities have to be our priorities and
of course they will look to us for
delivery and I will do my best to
deliver what is their priorities and at
the moment I don't have to tell anybody
in this room that people are suffering
from a cost of living crisis that'll be
my first intermediate priority to try to
help them in that regard so I've got
every confidence not just in my own
ability but frankly the ability of the
exceptional samp team that exists not
just in the Scottish Parliament as good
and exceptional as my MSP colleagues are
but right across the parliaments and
local government and our active activist
based through
uh Glen Campbell
congratulations uh on being elected how
can you possibly hope to unite the
country if you're still going to be
pushing hard for Independence one
dependence for me is a golden thread
that runs through so many of our
priority and policy areas the reason why
we can only mitigate the cost of living
crisis is because as a crisis that's
inflicted by Westminster we're doing so
with one hand tied behind our backs the
reason that why we can only invest in
our Public Services as much as we can is
because again our budget our fixed
budget is controlled by a Westminster
government so why we will deliver the
priorities of the people of Scotland
that will be to tackle the cost of
living crisis that will be to continue
to invest in our public services our NHS
of course in particular it'll be to make
progress on our well-being economy that
does not we will do that in tandem with
making the case for Independence because
Independence will unleash our country's
true potential
hello ah there we go
um the Turner in this election was only
70 so 30 of SMP members didn't even see
fit to vote what are you going to do to
engage them and is there a worry at all
the membership numbers could sink even
further no we'll be aiming to to
hopefully grow those membership numbers
and I hope people are inspired not just
by the contest and hopefully by the
outcome as well I hope people will join
the SNP as the vehicle that will deliver
Independence for Scotland in terms of
the 70 percent I think it's so important
for not just me but the team the SNP
team to make sure we are putting the
independent drive into fifth gear our
members are inspired and they'll be
inspired undoubtedly by the drive to
Independence we inspire people not by
getting stuck in a quagmire of process
and talking about section 30s and de
facto referendums they get inspired by
talking about policy and I've got I hope
the skills and the ability to be able to
inspire people with a vision for
Independence I believe that will help us
to increase our membership numbers but
also make sure all of our members are
involved in that campaign
I think we have um Stuart Green from ESP
I think we've got some International
media
there's a microphone coming to you
excellent I was just wondering uh with
Independence do you have a timeline of
when you'd like to see that happen and
um how would you convince those uh you
seems to be stuck on 45 they're simply
the same figures in 2014. uh many people
I speak to are are not convinced about
the economic plan the s p has how are
you going to reassure those people and
make them feel comfort that it's in
their interest to vote for Independence
that's a good question so our colleagues
in the Scottish media have been asking
me this for five weeks uh time and I'll
give them give you the same answer that
I give them which is of course a process
while it is important the key to getting
Independence is ensuring we have that
consistent majority support for
Independence we have that settled well
for Independence if we have that the
political obstacles that I put in our
that are put in our way by Westminster
well they will disappear so the
concentration will be on kickstarting
that civic-led Grassroots people-led
movement and growing consistency for
fund dependence and of course the
economic plan is absolutely key to that
so we have of course published papers
already on that but I think we've got
more work absolutely to do to convince
people we wouldn't be standing here if
that wasn't the case so one of the first
things I'll get on with doing as well as
governing and delivering and governing
rail I hope it will also be to make sure
we kick start that Independence Movement
um Maria or Maria forgive me from alzina
nope
okay
um we've got uh Alan Smith from Bower
congratulations in response to the
question from Colin you said in terms of
uniting the party speaking with both
Kate and Ash does that mean there'll be
room around your cabinet table for both
of your leadership Rivals and and just
secondly
um in terms of the vote just over 26 000
first and second preference votes means
you become a simply leader ultimately
becoming first Minister what do you see
then in response to opposition parties
who who will claim that you have no
mandate to govern and perhaps there
should be an election
so um look I I salute the fact that
you've been asking me for weeks now uh
Alan for exclusive uh on my cabinet uh
that is something of course that I'll be
giving consideration to and announcing
uh in due course but I've never shied
away from seeing both Kate and Ash uh
not just exceptional talents within our
party but have clearly got a role to
play a continued role in Scottish public
life in terms of the Mandate that of
course Parliament will have it say uh
tomorrow although I am party leader at
the moment there will be a vote and
there will be an opportunity for the
opposition uh to put their candidate
forward it is not by coincidence or
somehow good fortune that we are the
largest party in that Scottish
Parliament that is down to the fact that
the people of Scotland have given us
that Mandy have put their trust in us
and tomorrow as I say I will be one of
the nominees certainly to be first
minister of Scotland and others will
have their chance to Jack from Global
radio
congratulations
um you take over leader of the SNP at a
time when there are a lot of question
marks over the party's finances that
have been renewed reports over the
weekend over
um accusations of quite murky Financial
dealings there what are you going to do
as leader to reassure the members of
your party but also the people in
Scotland who are concerned about that
and to to reassure them that this isn't
an issue well again uh I I suspect I'll
get up to speed very quickly on the
financial health of the party it's not
something I've obviously been involved
in not holding a an office being in a
position within the party but what I
would say is that a party will be
transparent in terms of the finances and
of course I couldn't comment on what is
a live investigation either but I
suspect it will be one of the very first
conversations I have as party leader to
understand uh the financial health of
the SNP
uh we'll go to some print colleagues as
well Paul at the Daily Record hi there
um you're going to lead a government
that is struggling on a range of fronts
um your party is under police
investigation over its finances and the
chief executive resigned after lies were
trolled about membership numbers so
haven't you got the worst job in
Scottish politics I've got the best job
in Scottish politics by far the honor
and the privilege of not just leading
the SNP but potentially being Scotland's
the next uh first Minister that I am
here at a party that is the most popular
in Scotland by quite some distance I I
hit a party that has the largest
membership by quite some considerable
distance I have uh inherited a leader
the government that has a record of
achievement that would be the Envy of
any other government not just across
these islands but in many other parts of
the world to have their challenges you
betcha in government that always are
I've been in government for 10 and a
half years I've never been in a
portfolio never seen a portfolio with
their own challenges but that is why we
step up we step up to lead and I hope by
governing well we will also lead people
to Independence uh that's not Rachel
thank you and I just on you have said
that you want to unite Scotland
um on this but then you in the hostings
you spoke a lot about independence
referendum you were asked questions
about five years for example would
Scotland be Independence within five
years you said you want to govern for
all Scotland and represent everyone no
matter their political beliefs and how
do you square that are you not just
going to be as divisive as Nicholas
sturgeon felt she was when she left well
again Nicholas dungeon enjoyed huge
amounts of support her leadership
through the coveted pandemic in
particular saw so many people who told
me certainly on the doorsteps that they
wouldn't even have been contemplated
voting for The SNP but it's a leadership
that she she showed during that period
And so too must I and the government
that I lead we must show leadership we
must deliver for the priorities of the
people of Scotland I've already outlined
what I think those priorities are if we
do that then we win the trust of people
who win the trusted people they will
undoubtedly be persuaded by our message
on Independence so we can do both we can
both campaign for Independence I don't
think anybody would expect the leader of
the SNP to see anything other than that
but we can also make sure that we
deliver rightly for the people of
Scotland and their priorities too
um we've got the national Abbey
hi there
um hi thumbs up congratulations I just
wanted to ask a quick couple of
questions so obviously everything goes
well tomorrow Hive over here obviously
everything goes well tomorrow you will
be first minister so what is the first
thing you're going to do to bring
Scotland closer to Independence and
obviously you've done an interview with
our newspaper during the campaign
children you said that your cabinet
which I know you said you didn't want to
give away today that you would appoint a
minister for Independence so just
wondering if you had made any decisions
on that yeah well I will stick to those
commitments I made of course during the
campaign Trail for me one of the first
things I want to do is see how we
Kickstart that Civic LED campaign for
Independence it's got to be a Grassroots
lead it can't just be political leaders
uh sitting in a room devising strategies
on the way forward as important as the
leadership is uh of those who belong in
the independence movement has got to be
a Civic LED people-led movement that
drives forward the campaign for
Independence in terms of cabinet
ministerial appointments of course I'll
make them known uh energy course uh
Daily Mail Michael Blackley
hi hello in terms of two issues that
have debated the country you talk about
reaching out to non-ess voters
um two of the the key issues have been
uh the continued push for Independence
which you've talked quite substantially
about today uh will you continue to use
public money and Civil Service time
drawing up the prospectus for
Independence and on the grr Bill uh will
you be challenging the UK government
section 35 order
so uh generally I think when a party
wins an election and as thoroughly as
the s p has it has every right of course
to make sure it makes good on the
Promises in its Manifesto and we will do
that and of course at the Civil Service
will help us to deliver on all of our
Manifesto which includes of course uh
Independence we won the election quite
comprehensively in 2021 so just as the
UK government have the right to use
their civil service to pursue their
Ambitions around the Constitution it
should be no surprise that we will work
with the Civil Service to do the same
for Independence in terms of the glr
Bell I've made my position absolutely
clear on the section 35 I see it as a as
a veto as a paragraph by the UK
government I don't think they have any
right to have used that at section 35
power given that the majority of
Hollywood of course backed the grr bill
so of course my first principle my
starting principle
um is to challenge that section 35 order
Peter will be meeting very patiently
from ITV borders
there's a microphone coming to pizza
here or you can project if you wish
is that microphone coming
thank you
I hope this is worth waiting for
so do I uh when you were in Dumfries in
March campaigning you said we should
plant our flag in the ground right here
to let people know that they are not
forgotten people in the southwest and
south of Scotland and secondly we intend
to persuade every single person of the
merits of Independence that's why I want
to start the campaign for Independence
right here
so firstly how do you persuade people in
the south of Scotland they haven't been
forgotten and secondly when we be going
to Dumfries to launch your campaign very
soon very soon because I believe that
the only way we and we went into our
independence is persuading those that of
course who vote to know and are still
not persuaded by the case for
Independence and therefore we have to
take the case to not just a recent
gallery to the borders to the South uh
of Scotland and we do that again by
God's will we make sure that there are
opportunities for people in the south of
Scotland we make sure we invest in the
infrastructure in the south of Scotland
we make sure we support the well-being
economy of the south of Scotland and we
do that by governing and governing well
forgive me I've just been told uh
minutes ago that I'm leader of the SNP
I'll need to check the diary but I'll be
getting to them free share as soon as I
possibly can I'll need to leave it there
because there are a range of other
commitments that I have to make I want
to thank you again to the leader to the
members of the SNP to our
parliamentarians who are seated here to
our campaign team importantly to my
family for all the support and all the
encouragement that they have given me we
have a lot of work to do and get on with
so I suggest you go on with it thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you
well there we have it Hamza Yusuf is the
new leader of the SNP the Scottish
national party uh 70 of the SNP uh
electorate that were able to vote voted
and he won uh comprehensively on he won
on the first round but not enough to
give him a full mandate